(playful music)
- I hate touching.
- Makes me anxious.
- I don't like touching people
and I don't like touching things.
- Ever since I was little, I hated it.
- I've learned to pretend like
I don't know what a hug is.
- If you stay out of arms
reach, they can't get ya.
- I see somebody I know,
and I'll smile from afar,
and then hide.
- It'd be nice if I could come out of this
and be less anxious about
having to touch other people.
- This is a problem of mine,
I should probably fix it.
- I'm sure that'll change once
I continue to go to therapy,
but as of right now, I
just like to be alone.
Some people just don't
like each other's smells.
If people thought I needed a hug,
people gave me a really good hug.
- Every person was so excited to hug.
I think people like hugs.
- [Woman] And they told
me I was a good hugger.
- It was nice to see sort of an outpouring
of support of people being
like, oh yeah, I'll hug you.
- [Brunette] It was just horrible,
it's just too much.
- [Man] I hugged my best friend,
who I've known for 12 years.
- [Woman In Striped Shirt] That was sweet.
- [Man] Right foot, blue.
Now we're twistin'.
- [Woman In Striped Shirt]
This is my nightmare.
- [Woman] Oh, God.
- People love this game.
- [Woman] Oh, God, I'm getting dizzy.
I'm so uncomfortable.
- Got pretty lucky.
- I just don't wanna do it.
I am one spin away from quitting.
(laughing)
- [Brunette] This is like yoga.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Yeah this is good stuff.
- No, that's it, that's it, that's it.
- I thought I was making great progress.
- I would like to not hate it so much.
- I wanted to quit from the beginning.
- If I were to practice my
social skills a little better,
I'd be a lot more willing to hug more.
- I hope after this,
I'm a huggy kind of guy.
- Maybe one day.
(upbeat music)